Eh bien bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo de type fond vert,
de type c'est pas ma caméra,
et de type c'est pas mon micro
qui est lui-même posé sur une poubelle !
Donc aujourd'hui je suis sur la chaîne de Juliette Tresanini.
On va vous dire, avec Juliette, des mensonges et des vérités.
Deux choses vraies, pour une anecdote fausse.
Chacun.
Et à chaque fois vous allez devoir déterminer quel est le mensonge
de Juliette et quel est mon mensonge.
Sur la chaîne vous avez toutes les ressources possibles et inimaginables pour déterminer ça.
Il va y avoir d'ailleurs quelqu'un d'autre  qui va chercher en direct
qui va aussi nous poser des questions comme ça ça va vous donner des indices
en la personne de William, alias DocSeven.
Deux anecdotes vraies, une anecdote fausse.
Tu peux nous poser toutes les questions que tu veux.
Juste, tu nous donneras pas tes conclusions finales.
- Okay !
Tu les donneras plus tard
parce que on fera la révélation de nos mensonges
dans une vidéo qu'on va tourner sur ta chaîne - Juliette Tresanini.
- C'est ça.
Je commence qu'il faut commencer par Juliette parce que elle est moins à l'aise.
Toi, de toute façon, tu vas être difficile à lire donc autant te prendre à la fin
-C'est chaud hein, c'est vraiment chaud !
- Alors là, tu vas nous dire la vrai ou la fausse ?
- Bien tenté. T'en veux une?
- Oh p*tain, elle est en stress total !
- Non mais je suis complétement en stress parce que je ments très très très très mal.
Je mens très très mal.
Et je suis déjà toute rouge.
On peut faire un truc contre ça, les palpitations et le fait de ...
- Euh ... le décès.
Bah, en même temps, maintenant je peux le dire, donc ça va... Je suis enceinte.
-HAHAHA
- Bah quoi ?
-C'est  génial ! Ok !
- Moi j'ai comme anecdote, c'est que j'ai mis quelqu'un de très proche enceinte.
Non je déconne !
[rires]
Alors ma première anecdote, c'est que ...
Ma premiere anecdote...
Attends, je suis en train de l'inventer ...
C'est que...
... c'est que, tout simplement,
pour la première fois, j'ai fait dans une émission TV,
tout un truc sur la mémoire, durant 30 minutes j'ai parlé de la mémoire.
Et à la toute fin, on m'a demandé de faire la promo de mon spectacle à l'Olympia,
On m'a dit "Comment il s'appelle votre spectacle qui sera à l'Olympia le  22 septembre 2018 ? Réservez ! "
J'ai pas retrouvé le nom de mon propre spectacle, mais vraiment !
On a été obligé de couper, j'ai été obligé d'aller voir sur internet
pour me rappeler comment s'appelait mon spectacle.
Et je suis tombé enceinte.
[rires]
Voilà !
- Il pose des questions ou pas ?
- Quand il veut, peut-être à la fin
- D'accord, ok.
Juliette : Le premier splif... on le dit encore "splif"?
Juliette : C'est un vieux nom des années 90.
Fabien Bah je suis né en 82, donc ça marche pour moi.
doc seven Ouais, attends c'est quoi un "splif" ?
Juliette Le premier joint ...
doc seven Ah ouais ok très bien !
juliette ... que j'ai fumé,
fabien Il est né en 2012
Juliette...c'était avec Tina Turner.
C'est son mari qui me l'a roulé.
- C'était où ?
- C'était à côté de Cahors, à Caillac dans un restaurant, dans le Lot.
- Qu'est-ce qu'elle faisait dans le Lot, Tina Turner ...
Juliette Bah, elle était là et j'étais là ... et j'ai fumé un splif avec elle.
Fabien Tout les ans, elle va dans le Lot fumer des slifs
Juliette On dit plus splif, toi tu dis quoi alors? Un joint ? ... une cigarette magique?
doc seven Je dis ... du contenu illicite.
Juliette Du contenu illicite.
Voilà.
Ca m'est arrivée qu'une seule fois.
- je dis de la DROGUE.
- C'est mal.
- Et grâce à toi m'a vidéo ne sera pas monétisée, merci beaucoup !
[rires]
Cherchez vous en même temps hein...
Euh... Alors ma deuxieme anecdote.
Laquelle est elle...
Eh bien j'étais invité par une grande marque
De cosmétiques... je vais pas dire le nom, pour faire un tout petit spectacle
Et il y avait le PDG qui était là et on m'avait dit
"Il restera que cinq minutes, il a pas le temps quoi" tu vois.
Et il a tellement pas eu le temps qu'il a regardé tout le spectacle
et qu'après, on a commencé à vanner ensemble et qu'on a fini
tout les deux à quatre heures du matin dans une cabane dans les arbres
A boire du champagne.
Juste tout les deux à se dépouiller
Et c'est une très très très très grosse boîte
et c'est vraiment le CIE de la boite... Voilà
- Et ca veut dire quoi "se dépouiller"  - Oh non
- Se dépouiller ?
Eh bien écoute...  - Boire beaucoup
- ...Viens samedi à la maison
Et tu verras.
-Très bien
Et c'était quand ça ?  - C'est... oula... il y a quelques années
2012 je pense...
Un truc comme ça.
Il y a cinq ans du coup.
- Dans les arbres... - C'était dans le Lot  - ...Pourquoi dans les arbres ?
[rires]
A caillac...
Il est bien plus fort que moi... T'as l'air beaucoup plus détendu
- Il a exactement le visage tout le temps.
- Bah moi aussi mais très crispé  tout le temps.
Troisième anecdote euh...
J'ai diné avec les bleus le lendemain de la coupe du monde de 98
A la même table que Dugari, Zizou
...Laurent Blanc
- Dans la même salle ?  - Non dans la même salle et à la même table
- Dans la même ville.
- Il y avait pas Barthes, par exemple, à ma table. Il était à la table d'à côté.
- Ah oui parce que si ils étaient tous à la même table, ça ferait une grande table
- Ils étaient pas tous à la même table.
Je t'ai cité ceux qui étaient à la mienne.
- Et ma dernière anecdote, c'est que j'ai... j'ai donné.
Alors j'allais dire des cours... Ce serait pas vrai... J'ai donné un cours
De cartomagie à Nicolas Sarkozy.
Directement à l'Elysée.
- Ok... Mais donc j'ai pas le droit de dire ce que je pense ?
- Si  - Tu peux poser si t'as envie de poser des questions.
- Pose des questions.
- Pourquoi t'es allé à l'Elysée déjà ?
- Pour donner un cours de cartomagie à Sarkozy  - T'es allé à l'Elysée juste pour ça ?
- Juste pour ça - Genre ils t'ont invité pour ça ?
- Alors en fait, ça vient d'une rencontre préalable avec Sarkozy
Et il faisait une soirée privée pour la remise de la médaille de j'sais pas quoi à Rachida Dati
Et il y avait Sarkozy qui était là.
Et j'ai fait des démonstrations etc... et il a fait :
"Dis donc c'est très rigolo tout ça. Est-ce que vous pourriez donner des cours ?" Etc...
Je fais "ouais".
-Quelle imitation !
Il te manque le petit, le petit toc.
Et donc j'ai dit ok, et c'est son directeur de cabinet qui m'a contacté après pour placer un cours,
j'ai donné un cours, on devait faire pleins de cours sur l'année, et après il y a eu tout le...
-Et c'était juste pour lui ?!
C'était que pour lui, uniquement pour lui.
-T'es enceinte depuis cobien de temps ?
-3 mois et une semaine
c'est pour ca que je peux le dire maintenant.
-Ouais t'as fait l'écho.
-Ouais j'ai fait l'écho.
-D'accord. Et c'était quoi l'autre encore ?
T'es enceinte, Tinna terner et c'est quoi le troisième ?
-C'est les bleus.
-D'accord, et il y avait qui a ta table ?
-Alors il y avait, extactement je peux te faire le plan de table.
-Vas-y.
-A ma gauche, tout de suite à ma gauche, il y avait Dugarry,
il y avait Laurent Blanc à ma droite,
il y avait en face de moi, Zizou,
et il y avait Lizarazou qui était à peu près là, et il y avait Adriana Karembeu mais pas son mari qui était à l'autre table avec Bartez.
-Ok.
-Et Zlatan.
-Non. [rires]
Pourquoi j'étais là ?
Parce que c'était une soirée de charité, enfin de charité... Oui, enfin organisée par Cartier,
et que à l'époque je sortais avec la petite amie du PDG de Cartier.
Je sortais avec le fils, pardon, du PDG de quartier.
J'étais la petite amie du fils du PDG de quartier.
-Ok.
-T'as changé deux fois d'orientation sexuelle en une phrase.
[rires]
Je suis très très stressée !
J'ai l'impression d'être au commissariat, il faut que j'avoue un truc et que j'ai rien fait.
-Ok.
Et du coup c'est quoi le nom de ton spectacle ?
-"Synchronicité".
Non ! Pu**** !
[rires]
T'as vu ?! Je fais encore... je me trompe encore !
C'est "Singularité".
-Pourquoi tu te trompes ?
-Parce que j'oublie...
C'est terrible ! Dès qu'il y a une caméra j'oublie j'ai l'impression.
C'est dingue.
Ou alors c'est hyper bien préparé de ma part.
-Ok. Non mais je pense savoir tous les deux... je pense avoir trouvé.
Alors on arrête la vidéo ici, à cet endroit là.
On va continuer cette discussion sur ta chaîne.
-Exact.
-Sur la chaîne de Juliette Tresanini.
Dont vous retrouverez le lien dans la description, ainsi que le lien de la chaîne DocSeven que vous avez juste là.
Mais qui n'aura aucun rapport avec cette vidéo.
-Oui, je suis passé par là, c'est tout...
-On lui a dit "Eh tu veux venir ?" il a fait "Ok."
-Donc on vous donnera les réponses dans ta vidéo.
J'ai juste envie aussi que vous cherchez par vous même, vous pouvez regarder les anciennes vidéos sur le mensonge et essayer de trouver ça.
Mettre vos hypothèses dans les commentaires, mais surtout détaillez votre hypothèse, dites "je pense que c'est tel souvenir parce que ceci, parce que cela..."
qu'on puisse essayer d'échanger, peut-être que je casserai des idées reçues après
peut-être même que je referai une vidéo après en fonction de vos commentaires.
Merci beaucoup, n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en l'air, de vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Parce que j'ai vu dans mes stats que la moitié d'entre vous ne sont pas abonné à la chaîne.
-C'est fou ça !
-C'est dingue ça !
Cliquez c'est gratuit.
-Profitez-en !
-Pour l'instant c'est gratuit.
Cliquez maintenant parce que YouTube va peut-être devenir payant et les abonnements qui sont déjà faits resterons gratuits.
-Allez ! L'incitation !
-Ha il a pas honte hein !
-Ha ça fait bizarre quand on le fait soit-même !
Merci ! Au revoir !
Salut !
-Merci ! Merci à toi ! Salut !
-Abonnez vous je rends.
[rires]
Fabien: Aujourd'hui il y a trois ronds: il y a le mien, il y a celui de Doc, et il y a le tien, celui de Juliette.
Doc: -Mais non parce qu'on peut pas mettre 3 ronds en fait.
Fab: -Ha c'est bête.
Juliette: -T'es sûr ?!
Doc: -Je pense.
Juliette: -Mais non !
Doc: -Je suis pas sûr.
Juliette: -Je crois que c'est trois.
Fab: -Bah on va voir qui c'est qui a raison.
Fab: -Alors il va en manquer un...
Je ne sais pas qui je vais préferer garder...
Doc: -Bah celui qui a le plus d'abonnés !